vous le disais il était 14 heures heure
de paris quand carlos ghosn n'a pris la
parole devant les journalistes du monde
entier s'étaient au press club de
beyrouth
il a commencé par une longue déclaration
liminaire d'une heure environ
où il a expliqué d'abord que il n'avait
pas voulu fuir la justice en quittant le
japon pour se réfugier au liban mais
bien au contraire c'est parce que la
justice n'était pas rendu là bas
écoutez un extrait et skate justin
haythe led edge à 6,1 persécutions
politiques aux persécutions avec des
yeux monde encore il y eu 28 system
design to break mis en ligne tout
progrès demi ivan minimale jazz six
oiselets où ils n'ont eu d'autre chose
bah tout protect myself and my family et
toi ces difficultés si jeune un risque
politique ce qui frise à toutes
possibilités offertes toi tu connais
fregosi en écoutant carlos ghosn est ce
que vous avez été convaincu par l'homme
après on reviendra sur les accusations
précises d'abus de bien social qui ont
été portées contre lui
mais quand il dit le japon n'est pas une
démocratie judiciaire
je devais m'enfuir est ce qui vous a
convaincu - il m'a convaincu sur deux
thématiques donc la première
effectivement m'enfin je n'avais pas
besoin d'être convaincu d'après tout ce
qu'on a entendu sur la justice japonaise
en effet elle ne répond pas à nos
critères en tous les cas et de respect
des droits de l'homme et des droits
civils mais nous y reviendrons donc si
j'ai bien compris ma aussi convaincu
d'une chose mais dont j'étais déjà
convaincu en fait c'est de là la façon
extravagante content de vivre les grands
capitalistes aujourd'hui mais c'est pas
nouveau et c'est pas propre à carlos
ghosn alors effectivement il s'est
notamment expliqué sur les fêtes
organisées à versailles à la fois pour
pour lui même et pour son entreprise
laurent alexandre une première réaction
à 7
cette conférence de presse déjà je suis
content de voir quelqu'un qui est un
plus mauvais accent anglais que moi
c'est qu'on comprend tout c'est tout à
fait réconfortant quand on voit la
complexité de cette affaire et la
difficulté de trancher des points de
droit fiscal et de droit des affaires à
cheval sur plusieurs pays à cheval sur
plusieurs droits il est impossible
d'après les éléments dont on a à
disposition aujourd'hui et après les
déclarations de gones de savoir si la
raison où il a tort d expertise
extrêmement poussée seraient nécessaires
pour savoir s'il ya abus de droit et si
ces rémunérations différées était
justifiée ou n'était pas justifié ce
sont des problèmes extrêmement compliqué
qu'on va pas on va pas résoudre qu'on va
pas régler après une conférence de
presse et ça on va y revenir mais sur le
fait que sa fuite du japon était
légitime mais ce que est ce que endroit
endroit fuir fuir à ses juges n'est
jamais légitime donc effectivement on a
découvert que le système judiciaire
français et débonnaire qu'on échappe
assez souvent à la prison que la garde à
vue est finalement plutôt cool et que la
préventive n'est pas invivable par
rapport à la situation japonaise mais en
droit ce n'est pas parce que la justice
est sévère qu'on a le droit d'échapper à
ses juges donc d'un point de vue
juridique il a tort il a peut-être
raison d'un point de vue moral et
politique et puis il a sûrement raison
d'un point de vue personnel parce que
c'est vrai qu'il a une a eu que quelques
minutes de conversation avec sa femme en
neuf mois
ce qui n'est quand même pas très sympa
j'ai fait la même chose à sa place à
solvin as vous saviez partie si vous
aviez pulsé l'écurie oui et puis je
trouve que cette affaire à quelque chose
a des accents un peu romanesque qui
m'amuse qui m'amuse aussi parce que
c'est pas un dossier qui concerne
directement vraiment la france lui vous
répondre et monsieur alexandre qu'il n'a
pas fui la justice et qu'il a fuie en
fait un procès politique
exactement procès politique quelque part
donc oui je peux comprendre s'il
s'aperçoit que les conditions en tout
cas que nos critères de justice ne sont
pas respectées qu'il a les moyens de
fuir
pourquoi ne pas le faire et disposer de
plusieurs passeports c'est c'est le jeu
quelque part il se passe quelque chose
d'assez étonnant
vincent trémolet de villers c'est que
comme vous le savez nos internautes
réagissent en direct sur twitter et
donnent leur point de vue et on vous
pose cette question suite à sa prise de
parole carlos ghosn vous at il convaincu
et bien pour l'instant c'est une égalité
parfaite autres
alors on est passé à 49 51 c'est honteux
ça évolue parce qu'on est en direct et
je n'arrive pas à voir parce que c'est
pas sur le grand écran quel est le point
de vue qui l'emportent ce sont les noms
dans quel toute petite majorité de gens
qui sont pas convaincus mais c'est quand
même très partagés ce cas votre avis
cette conférence de presser les de
nature à faire évoluer 7,7 ce ressenti
moi il me semble que oui parce que
d'abord il a quand même réussi une chose
dont il ya dans la vie à deux justiciers
le prétoire et puis le tribunal
médiatique et dans le tribunal
médiatique il a réussi une plaidoirie
quand même complètement bluffante
sur le plan de l'efficacité de la force
de conviction de l'autorité et puis à
capter l'attention comme personne
puisque personne ne l'avait entendu
depuis des mois sauf une interview dans
la presse écrite et donc il a réussi à
installer un personnage que beaucoup de
gens ne connaissaient pas connaissait
mal et je pense qu'il y à une mutation
dans la psychologie collective c'est à
dire que carlos ghosn c'est est ce que
vous disiez le grand patron qui vit sur
plusieurs continents à la fois avec un
niveau de vie et un train de vie décalé
avec tout le monde est là il est devenu
ce que vous disiez vous une personnalité
romanesque c'est à dire que les gens ont
suivi son évasion la malle et maintenant
regarde edmond dantès préparer sa
vengeance
et il le fait quand même avec énormément
de force le début de la conférence de
presse fait vraiment penser à des
plaidoiries qu'on a pu voir dans des
prétoires c'est à dire qu'il prend la
stratégie de la rupture absolue cette
île n'est coupable de rien et il est la
victime d'un complot et ça ne peut avoir
qu'une certaine efficacité vue à la fois
l'audience qu'il a réussi à réunir et la
ville avait pas de contradicteurs il y
avait simplement des questions et sa
capacité quand même sa force de
conviction qui quoi qu'on pense du fond
du dossier parce que il y avait des
endroits assez obscur est quand même
assez sidérante
ça monte on comprend moi j'avoue que je
ne suis pas journaliste économique donc
j'ai pas suivi carlos ghosn je voyais ça
de très loin et on comprend comment
cette personnalité a pu séduire
énormément et a pu être à la tête de
grandes entreprises d'être considérée
comme des patrons les plus exceptionnels
exister en france
vous le disiez frigo ainsi que la partie
qui va sûrement être très reprises parce
qu'elle est facile à comprendre sur les
fêtes à versailles
elle ne vous avait pas convaincu lui
disait ou bien c'était une fête pour
fêter l'alliance et que versailles
ça parle aux gens du monde entier donc
il était normal invité les partenaires
de l'entreprise ou bien c'était une fête
privée
il avait payé le traiteur et le service
mais pas le palais lieu parce que comme
c'est comme bruno médecins et msn on lui
avait fait ce petit cadeau souvenir il
sait pas non pas du tout non non non
vous savez il en faut beaucoup pour me
choquer vous le savez donc non non c'est
pas que je suis choqué du tout est à la
limite oui il a pu me convaincre
pourquoi pas non ce qui ressort de tout
ça sa défense c'est en fait cette façon
de vivre aujourd'hui dans ces grandes
entreprises et ce qui est aussi
extrêmement intéressant à discuter c'est
aussi de ces fusions de grandes
entreprises elles fusionnent pourquoi
elles fusionnent pour des raisons
financières avant tout même avant d'être
des raisons technologiques que ça on
pourrait comprendre mais on se retrouve
dans des contradictions entre le
capitalisme transnational et la
dimension nationale des entreprises les
intérêts nationaux en jeu également
donc on est vraiment là au delà du
personnage gones et moi avons héroïsé
les gens c'est pas tellement mon truc
mais au delà du personnage qui
effectivement je peux le comprendre
peut être fascinant parce qu'il a l'air
extrêmement intelligent et plein de de
qualité de capacité mais au-delà de
lui-même c'est tout le système
capitalistique d'aujourd'hui qui est
mise en lumière je dirais et donc eh
bien oui c'est normal pour une grande
entreprise d'avoir besoin d'avoir une
image de marque donc c'est normal de
faire des fêtes à versailles c'est
normal d'être un mécène
aujourd'hui le mécénat des entreprises
c'est quelque chose qui est devenu banal
or c'est pas du tout évident une
entreprise est ce que c'est fait pour ça
enfin bon en fait dont celle à faire on
découvre un monde où les médias c'est
c'est un monde qui nous est pas familier
et qu'on doit connaître et analyser
donc c'est extrêmement intéressant un au
delà du personnage romanesque c'est vrai
nom poursuit ce que vous dites et les
comparaisons romanesque ou littéraire
c'est quand même pas le fruit du
capitalisme contemporain qui est des
machinations à très haut niveau avec des
enjeux financiers c'est le coeur du 19e
siècle français qui peut-être n'était
pas sur tous les continents mais c'est
pour ça à mon avis que l'affairé gones
captive
c'est qu'elles concentrent les lieux de
pouvoir les lieux financiers les
capacités de la nature humaine à se
battre et il ya toute l'intensité qu'il
ya beaucoup moins en politique c'était
tout début alors on comprenait pas tout
sur conseil d'administration nissan
quand on est moi j'avoue qu'il ya
vraiment j'ai des moments j'étais perdu
mais tout le début on se croirait dans
un roman politique et on a l'impression
que le transfert du pouvoir s'est fait
dans cette enseigne l'arabe alors
justement quand je traversé le temps
carlos ghosn a expliqué pourquoi est ce
que il avait quitté le japon
il a aussi essayé de démontrer que les
accusations portées contre lui n'étaient
pas justifiés par exemple la justice
japonaise le procureur l'a accusé
d'avoir eu des rémunérations cacher et
d'avoir une espèce non pas de questions
armée de réserve d'argent librement à sa
disposition pour distribuer à ses
collaborateurs au directeur pas du tout
a répondu carlos ghosn tout ça était
très organisé très planifiée at il
montré peut-être preuves à l'appui je ne
sais pas en tout cas voilà la séquence
son revenu justement sur ces montants
dix ans mais regardez ce sont des fonds
secrets que carlos ghosn a reçu et c'est
un mensonge
si on prenait donc la réserve par
exemple accordé
au pdg du différé et bien tout ça
effectivement c'est publié sur le site
ça n'a rien de secret laurent alexandre
vous êtes non seulement aux médecins et
narco est aussi entrepreneur vous avez
un billet d'accès donc a priori la
finance ça vous parle
mais vous nous disiez tout à l'heure
qu'en fait il était difficile à travers
des propos comme celui qu'on vient
d'entendre de savoir si tout ça est
légal ou pas alors sur ce qui est de ses
rémunérations différées un qui est l'une
des grosses accusations des japonais
c'est très compliqué carlos ghosn voyage
énormément
il a trois passeports il entreprit est à
cheval sur plusieurs pays avec des
holdings qui soit encore dans dans des
nouveaux pays et des holdings dans
d'autres pays que le japon et la france
de savoir où il est vraiment résident
fiscal français
quel droit s'applique dans quel dans
quelle mesure c'est le drôle landais le
droit français le droit le droit
japonais qui qui qui s'applique c'est
extrêmement compliqué s'il y avait eu
procès ça aurait été le fruit de deux
batailles d'experts extrêmement
compliqué il est exclu de pouvoir
trancher après cette conférence de
presse alors les réactions sont assez
nombreuses citoyen paye en audi une
justice que l'on peut fuir quel
formidable invention je sais pas si ça
veut dire que c'est la justice japonaise
qui doit être soutenu
claudius 15 n'est absolument pas
convaincu par un homme qui fuit la
justice certainement pas ajoute-t-il
et puis flight 94 affirme qu'il est
facile de juger après coup des décisions
dont on ne connaît pas le contexte du
moment
et puis cette question mais presque
abyssal de chardons bleus il s'est bien
défendu maintenant peut-on le croire
entièrement c'est le bide à ça c'est la
vérité d'un homme c'est propre à chacun
et puis
visiblement on n'aura pas le fin mot de
l'histoire parce que on sait qu'à pas
d'accord d'extradition entre le liban le
japon etc
visiblement le procès ne se tiendra
jamais maintenant ce qui pourrait
entacher son image puisqu'on parlait
tout à l'heure de l'image de l'opinion
publique
du moins l'opinion publique française
c'est peut-être l'effet de versaillaise
les français sont de plus en plus
sensibles à l'égard de ces questions là
on sait qu'il ya une rupture entre les
élites et le reste des français
c'est ce qui pourrait voilà le plus
fragilisé si je puis dire dans son image
c'est un élan dernier monsieur à la
retraite qui va se reposer au liban
jusqu'à la fin de ses jours maintenant
sauf miracle donc je pense qu'il s'en
fout oui oui tout à fait il s'en fichent
de nous parler simplement ton image a
rafraîchi pas comment ils vont rebondir
de calais puy gas et il va être très
occupés dans les années à venir avec la
volonté peut-être de régler à cet
automne pour répondre à cordon bleu qui
nous demandent est-ce qu'on peut le
croire entièrement ya un point sur
lequel on a droit de ne pas le croire
c'est quand il a accusé ses successeurs
à la tête de renault nissan d'avoir
foire et la fusion avec chrysler fiat
parce que la vérité c'est que le nouveau
patron du groupe renault jean dominique
senard était très attaché à cette fusion
est que si elle s'est pas fait c'est pas
parce qu'il est un incapable qui
manquait de volonté
c'est parce que le gouvernement français
l'état étant actionnaire de renault le
lui a interdit dans au moins sur ce
point là en tout cas carlos ghosn n'est
pas mon avis tout à fait tout à fait
clair et tout à fait convaincant si vous
le voulez